[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission qui
pourrait s'appeler un versaillais à New
York versailler c'est Didier Kimmel
bonjour Alors Didier vous êtes l'auteur
d'un roman qui s'appelle les roses
bleues on en reparlera peut-être tout à
l'heure on en avait déjà parlé ici lors
de sa sortie c'était il y a quelques
mois au mois de février
à New York parce que grâce à ces roses
bleues vous avez été conviés à salon
d'écrivains qui a lieu à New York c'est
ça oui tout à fait Patrice en fait
effectivement c'est une aventure un peu
surprenante parce que comme on se
l'était dit l'autre fois moi c'est mon
premier roman je suis un nouvel auteur
j'ai noté comme on avait dit un nouvel
acteur mais effectivement quand j'ai
écrit ce roman j'ai eu le plaisir de le
voir être publié je n'imaginais pas que
il me répondit jusqu'à New York le rêve
américain et ça ça a été une surprise
que j'ai eu et que j'ai pu vivre le 22
novembre à New York dans un endroit
prestigieux qui s'appelle The National
Art club c'est c'est un club tout à fait
remarquable qui qui fait la promotion de
l'art français d'une façon générale et
qui dans lequel on a pu effectivement on
était une trentaine d'auteurs venus de
trois continents différents et oui
francophone effectivement savoir que à
New York rien qu'à New York je crois que
c'est un Sandrine tout à l'heure qui est
là
allez parce que on a on a la chance et
la joie d'être avec Sandrine mairesse
depuis New York
bonjour New York bonjour Sandrine
c'est vous en effet
c'est vous en effet qui a de
l'organisatrice de de ce festival alors
on va parler un petit peu de votre
parcours tout tout à l'heure mais
pourquoi vous avez invité par exemple
Didier qui mène
j'ai
invité auteur francophone international
qui est né à New York mais qui
aujourd'hui
dans de nombreux pays puisqu'on a 340
auteurs de 44 pays du monde 45 + ce
matin j'ai rentré ça Singapour comme 45e
pays et donc quand j'ai lancé l'idée de
monter cette seconde édition parce qu'on
a fait l'année dernière en plein covid
cette seconde édition du festival des
auteurs francophones en Amérique un des
premiers à dire j'y vais je suis là je
suis avec toi c'était Didier donc Didier
nous a rejoint bien évidemment les
auteurs sont sélectionnés donc on a
sélectionné Didier parce que la jolie
parcours un joli livre et une jolie
envie de dépasser les frontières donc
voilà comment Didier et son premier
roman se sont retrouvés à cette seconde
édition du festival qui était par année
par Marc Levy donc on avait un très joli
à qui justement s'adresse ce festival
qui sont les qui sont les gens qui
viennent visiter c'est plutôt des
Américains de New Yorkais c'est plutôt
des Français qui vivent à New York
alors chaque année un peu différente
j'ai envie de dire que cette année était
un peu différente parce que on était à
la veille des Thanksgiving et vous savez
peut-être faire living c'est la la fête
la plus importante aux États-Unis où on
voyage le plus donc on a perdu un peu de
francophones et francofiles américains
cette année qui était parti en famille
mais on a eu un public francophone assez
hétéroclide des Européens on a eu des
Belges on est aussi les Québécois qui
sont venus nombreux parmi les auteurs
parmi les représentants officiels et
puis on a eu des gens un peu partout
parce que la francophonie était là on a
eu des francophones d'Égypte on a eu des
francophones de Suisse et que
francophone américain aussi
oui parce que les Américains d'une façon
générale et new-yorkais peut-être plus
particulièrement sont quand même
toujours attirés par la culture
française
et vous en êtes un exemple
et on a la chance moi j'ai toujours que
notre Francophonie est
passeport français est un magnifique
passeport partout parce que la France
reste en tout cas à New York une espèce
de passeport qui fait rêver les
Américains avec des étoiles dans les
yeux donc on est c'est vrai on a les
gros Clichy nous collaient à la peau
mais on va dire tant mieux et c'est vrai
que quand vous parlez à New York avec
votre accent français comme c'est le cas
pour moi
créer une espèce de magie chez votre
interlocuteur donc oui il y a beaucoup
de francophones on apprend le français
dans les écoles publiques dans tous les
lycées publics on apprend le français à
New York et il y a une vraie volonté
pour beaucoup de New Yorkais de
s'attacher à prendre un tout petit peu
de la culture française des francophones
vous pouvez nous dire une petite phrase
en anglais là pour qu'on qui séduit tant
les Américains
[Musique]
et ça c'est génial parce que
je ne sais pas comment qualifier ça mais
c'est vrai que voilà vous avez reconnu
le français dans votre accent mais je
pense que vous mettez très bien les
accents toniques et que par conséquent
il vous comprennent très précisément non
Patrice
j'ai un mari complètement bilingue j'ai
un mari qui a fait ses études aux
États-Unis et maman anglaise et parfois
on dit la même phrase mais on n'est pas
compris la même façon et je ne sais
toujours pas pourquoi après 17 ans dans
ce
une grande modestie qui habite Sandrine
un peu de ce parcours comment vous êtes
arrivés à New York est-ce que vous y
faites parce que vous représentez
beaucoup la culture française à New York
mais Didier alors racontez-nous voilà ce
comment s'est passé ce voyage cette
découverte non peut-être vous connaissez
New York mais oui mais toutefois ça a
été un moment magique bien naturellement
parce que encore une fois quand j'ai
écrit ce roman je t'éloigne imaginer que
j'aurai l'opportunité de me rendre à New
York c'est quand même des petits salons
d'auteur pourquoi pas mais voilà c'est
ça voilà tout à fait donc
je remercie toujours bien sûr Sandrine
de m'avoir convié parce que c'était un
moment formidable d'ailleurs c'était
intéressant parce que en fait c'est 30
auteurs on se connaît plutôt via les
visioconférences il y a quelques-uns
qu'on rencontre le plus souvent c'est
par connexion etc et là c'était une
journée finalement oui mais en fait
comme ils sont de plusieurs pays comme
on l'avait compris on n'est pas on n'est
pas certain du tout de se rencontrer et
là ça a été l'occasion à nous 32 nous
rencontrer et Sandrine avait organisé
une journée finalement qui a débuté par
un petit déjeuner dans un endroit fort
sympathique où là on a pu effectivement
ce connaît discuter et puis c'est de la
discussion que ressort aussi
l'envie d'écrire les encouragements
l'inspiration pourquoi pas et de voir
tous ces expériences partager tous ces
expériences là ça a été vraiment un
moment magnifique donc ça c'était le
matin et puis l'après-midi donc on a eu
ce salon dans un endroit encore une fois
tout à fait prestigieux avec la chance
mais incroyable de voir quelqu'un comme
Marc Levy qui est quand même
plus dans le monde aujourd'hui
sympathie d'une simplicité et qui est
venue nous porter une parole nous
encourager vraiment ça ça a été pour
nous tous très touchant parce que c'est
quand même un monsieur nous on est
vraiment minuscules à côté de lui et il
a été vraiment d'une sympathie
romantique il est il est très modeste
une petite anecdote avec avec Marc Levy
il se trouve que je sortais un livre en
même temps que lui et qu'on était invité
à une émission c'était c'était durant
qui présentait la mission littéraire à
l'époque sur France 2 donc on était
invité et on était à côté de l'autre il
est tellement timide qu'il me dit écoute
si m'interroge je parle à ma place
[Rires]
donc c'est vrai que c'est il est d'une
gentillesse et de simplicité absolument
remarquable alors que comme vous le
dites c'est le c'est le l'auteur
français qui alors évidemment on vante
qui est le numéro 1 et c'était le jour
en plus ou si je me souviens
son dernier roman donc il avait je pense
une grosse occupation plus sens du vigne
d'or mais malgré tout il est venu nous
rejoindre et ça a été un moment
formidable son fils a un restaurant non
à New York
non
restaurant à New York
peut-être qu'il l'avait peut-être qu'il
a plus je ne sais pas en tout cas voilà
oui donc c'est quel était les gens sont
venus voir vous parler je suppose alors
c'était c'est quoi plutôt des des il
vous connaissez non je pense pas moi
c'est une concerne il me connaissait pas
c'était des gens qui étaient attirés par
bien sûr la littérature française et qui
sont venus discuter avec nous très
librement tout ce tout se former bien
passé ils ont demandé qu'est-ce que
c'est les roses bleues
parce que moi en fait j'ai l'impression
que la plupart la plupart de ceux ou de
celle plutôt qui j'ai pu m'entretenir
était français expatrié Sandrine
de discussion et permet effectivement
d'avoir des échanges assez intéressants
à la fois sur les roses bleues ou sur le
sous-titre d'ailleurs
pouvait se conjuguer au pluriel
et c'est très intéressant effectivement
de de pouvoir s'entretenir avec les gens
de discuter avec eux certains vous
disent pourquoi les roses bleues
d'autres
le pitch du livre c'est un scientifique
qui veut acheter une veste qui se rend
dans un magasin de mode et il y a une
styliste qui est là donc il est il est
assez touché par la styliste et il est
même un peu lourdon quoi dans son
approche donc il se dit il faut quand
même que je fasse quelque chose pour
m'excuser et il lui offre voulu faire
vous voyez des roses bleues c'est comme
ça que c'est comme ça que le l'histoire
et les deals
et les roses bleues alors on peut le
préciser parce que qu'est-ce que c'est
parce que les roses bleues ça existe pas
dans la nature évidemment ça n'existe
pas dans la nature et en particulier
dans dans mon roman qui se passe sur on
va dire de générations dans la première
partie c'est rose bleu n'existe pas
comme vous le dites dans la nature et ce
sont des roses blanches ou crème qu'on
colore avec un colorant alimentaire et
qui les rendent bleus mais effectivement
elle n'existe pas et ses roses bleues
par contre elle n'existe pas mais elles
sont dans la littérature depuis
des siècles elles apparaissent dans
l'état de la vie des siècles donc c'est
assez mystérieux donc les véhicule le
mystère un véhicule les excuses et puis
elles ont un petit côté
[Musique]
étonnant voilà et donc elle confère à
ceux ou celles qu'ils reçoivent la
capacité d'exaucer des vœux donc ça
c'est dans la première partie de mon
roman dans la deuxième partie donc
quelques 30 ans plus tard bien sûr
les hommes ont fait des recherches parce
que ils aiment pas être de buter devant
quelque chose il y a pas de rose bleu
comment ça se fait donc il y a eu des
manipulations génétiques qui ont permis
effectivement d'isoler un des pigments
qui s'appelle la Delphine idine et les
Australiens les américains japonais sont
parvenus à créer une fleur assez
naturelle qui qui est une rose bleue
maintenant et d'ailleurs quand j'étais à
New York sur les Simpson avenue j'ai
trouvé des roses bleues naturelles alors
que j'ai voulu en ramener là aujourd'hui
au studio je n'ai pas réussi à en
trouver
de Versailles et j'en ai trouvé
seulement des colorés donc je les ai pas
amenés je les ai achetés mais je sais
pas amener voilà et alors qu'à New York
j'en ai trouvé des magnifiques
non parce que non
c'est pas bien ça non c'est pas bien
mais en fait on est passé je vais pas
raconter tous les détails de l'aventure
américaine mais on avait un timing très
serré
j'ai pas pris le temps effectivement
voilà mais on a fait autre chose pour
remercier Sandrine donc voilà donc
rencontre avec les avec des lecteurs
avec des gens qui habitent qui habite
New York
Sandrine alors un mot sur vous quand
même vous êtes au départ vous êtes une
journaliste
je fume une journaliste il y a très
longtemps un petit mot sur les roses
bleues quand même parce que j'ai une
agence d'événements de production
événementielle aux États-Unis et c'est
dans ce pays que j'ai appris à faire les
roses bleues parce que les gros yeux
s'entraînement dans les réceptions et
donc j'ai avec des fleuristes d'un
compte trempé effectivement les tiges et
qu'on les laissait qu'elle devenait bleu
après après 24 ou 48 heures le petit
lien avec le roman oui moi je suis venue
aux États-Unis en 2006 donc il y a déjà
plus de 16 ans et avec mon mari nous
avons continué ce que nous faisions en
France qui était l'événementiel et très
vite on est devenu un peu d'agence des
grands événements français aux
États-Unis qu'on a fait une très belle
chose et puis et puis voilà et puis en
2018 je me suis enfin
forcé
à prendre la plume que je prenais depuis
toujours pour ressentir mon premier
roman j'ai un est sorti un deuxième et
puis donc en 2020 50 ans de mariage
on est aussi dans les couleurs
qui a un problème de visibilité aux
États-Unis qui me disait moi-même en
grande maison je suis invisible ici donc
je me suis dit comment je peux mettre à
profit mon espérance professionnelle de
communicante ma passion des mots et de
la lecture et de la littérature et voilà
c'est la naissance des rencontres des
auteurs francophones qui a un vrai
réseau de coeur et moi je veux dire tous
les matins je me lève avec les petits
mots des auteurs du bout du monde et je
peux vous dire que je commence ma
journée différemment que que la plupart
des gens grâce à ça ça fait du bien
alors j'ai vu que vous aviez organisé
évidemment des événements incroyables
comme le best of France à Times Square
qui a réuni plus de 500 000 personnes
c'est vous qui avez largué alors c'était
pour les 70 ans d'idées un million de
pétales de roses déjà pas forcément
besoin au-delà au dessus de la statue de
la liberté c'est ça
de produire des gros challenges mais bon
pardon et vous avez aussi pardon produit
pour la télévision française aussi
non
on a produit pas mal de choses avec
enfin notamment avec Jean-Claude nassiq
que vous connaissez
avec nous antonination on a fait pas mal
de choses on n'a pas produit d'émission
sur les éclipes de soleil je crois enfin
du siècle en 1999 a été produite en
collaboration avec une chaîne et ces
gens comme narcis effectivement c'est
comme ça qu'on est devenu amis en 1999
une amitié qui se poursuit toujours et
en fait toujours de belles choses
ensemble
et vous revenez de temps en temps en
France
je reviens tout le temps en France
globalement entre deux et trois fois par
an à partir 2023 je vais revenir un
petit peu plus parce que je veux
vraiment développer cette plateforme
littéraire on a déjà ouvert la Belgique
en octobre lors du salon de Mons avec
20000 personnes et et voilà on va on va
se développer aussi en France on a des
actions à faire en Italie donc voilà je
vais passer de nombreux mois en
France
mais après une mission de cœur
vous a la chance de vous avoir avec nous
c'est quoi l'atmosphère la New York
à cette époque de Noël c'est plutôt
enchanté c'est plutôt une ville gay une
ville un souci en tout
ouais c'est c'est ma palette très
préférée et vous avez c'est comme dans
les films vous avez des
l'Armée du Salut avec les cloche qui
chante qui danse comme dans les films
des années 50 dans tous les magasins à
la radio il y a les standards de de Noël
qui font un bien fou même si c'est
répétitif il y a des patinoires il y a
les marchés de Noël et ensuite vous
croyez au bout du monde il y a une
atmosphère vraiment particulière les
vitrines sont un peu moins décorées
qu'il y a quelques années mais c'est là
c'est là les grands magasins sont là
l'atmosphère est là donc elle est
chaleureuse même si New York c'est
c'est un peu appauvri dans certains
quartiers même si être plus en plus de
de de
personnes sans domicile fixe ou même si
la ville prend parfois une tenait un peu
un peu difficile à voir pour nous c'est
vrai que c'est pas la vie qu'on a connu
avant le vide elle s'est relevée
complètement en termes de population en
termes d'énergie mais c'est pas la ville
de la
banque peut-être que Didier a pu le voir
puisque il l'a vu et qu'il ne
connaissait la ville avant je crois
qu'elle a changé depuis depuis deux ou
trois ans mais mais on peut quand même
recommander à ceux qui n'ont pas fait
d'aller passer si on peut aller passer
les fêtes à New York c'est quand même
c'est quand même un beau souvenir
c'est quand même un moment formidable
cette année donc vous pouvez y aller il
y a des anneaux il fait très très froid
avec nous quand vous revenez vous venez
nous parler mais merci beaucoup d'avoir
parce que
mission c'est le matin c'est tout encore
pour vous
non ça va vous êtes réveillés vous êtes
en forme
vous inquiétez pas oui
Didier
formidable formidable donc aventure avec
ses roses bleues
vous avez envie de continuer je suppose
oui oui j'ai continué d'ailleurs j'ai
envoyé mon deuxième roman qui s'appelle
au même éditeur oui alors il y a
plusieurs raisons
s'appelle je ne serai jamais loin de toi
et en fait
j'ai pu être de Marc Levy mais presque
presque mais finalement il se fait bon
très modestement je le dis je ne compare
pas du tout à lui mais c'est vrai qu'il
y en a pas mal de de choses où on peut
trouver des
donc en tout cas c'est quelqu'un qui
inspire beaucoup eu certainement sur sa
façon sa ligne etc et donc je ne sera
jamais loin de toi c'est en fait
l'histoire alors j'écris un roman qui
qui peut se lire sans avoir lieu le
précédent les roses bleues d'accord
je suis persuadé que ceux qui n'auront
pas lu les roses bleues et qui
commenceront par le deuxième auront
certainement envie de lire le premier
mais je l'ai écrite de telle façon qu'il
soit autoportant autonome complètement
autonome donc si vous n'avez pas vu le
premier vous lisez le deuxième tout se
passe bien si vous avez lu le premier en
plus c'est pas mal donc en fait de toi
et ça sort ça sort janvier février
et donc là ça sera l'histoire je vais
vous le dire très brièvement de
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Marc toujours
qui n'arrive pas à se faire à l'idée de
la disparition de Diane il arrive pas
c'est un truc qui qui le travaille
vraiment et il va avoir
il va il va disperser avec le fils de
Diane les cendres de James justement et
ont dispersant ses cendres ils vont
découvrir une petite boîte métallique
dont laquelle il va y avoir un certain
nombre de choses qui vont leur permettre
de se transporter disons de d'avoir une
connexion 70 ans plus tôt pas une
commission réelle mais avec les
recherches ils vont réussir à trouver
qui enfouis cette boîte retrouver les
descendants discuter et là où Marc va
avoir un petit souci c'est que il va
trouver beaucoup de coïncidence de
correspondance de d'analogie qui vont
vraiment le perturber et qui vont le
conforter dans l'idée que
j'accepte pas la disparition de Diane et
donc lui il va se mettre à penser que
peut-être qu'il y a des choses qui sont
bien plus fortes que ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on ressent et
ça me faisait penser à Marc Levy et si
c'était vrai oui son premier tout à fait
alors
où on peut aller au-delà de la mort
c'est ça c'est donc l'idée que est-ce
que finalement
lui c'est un scientifique comme vous le
savez ce scientifique là il est plutôt
disons cartésien etc donc on vous dit
vous êtes mort bon bah ok on se dit
c'est fini et ben lui il se dit ok on
accepte cette idée mais mais moi je
voudrais bon voilà donc est-ce qu'on
peut communiquer avec les défunts les
choses comme ça voilà c'est ça qui va se
passer il va faire des recherches il va
lire il va avoir plein de choses qui
vont l'inciter à penser que est-ce que
c'est certain que une fois que la mort
du corps et là est-ce que c'est vraiment
continuent et il va s'apercevoir en
lisant dans la littérature les religions
il y a plein de choses différentes il va
consulter des gens il va il va vraiment
faire des recherches voir un médium et
puis finalement il va aller juste en
Inde et donc l'aventure se poursuit
alors ce roman aussi au départ il a un
petit fond historique parce que comme je
vous l'ai dit il va remonter à 70 ans et
on va on va revivre si c'est passé 70
ans ce garçon qui a enterré cette petite
boîte et cetera donc c'était pendant
l'occupation allemande sur le Bassin
d'Arcachon bien sûr dans les années 42
et donc c'est un garçon qui est appelé
régime Vichy il y avait le service de
travail obligatoire et qui résiste il
veut pas aller au service obligatoire
voilà et qui résiste et tu sais bien que
il va se faire arrêter dans peu de temps
parce que ça peut pas durer comme ça
voilà donc c'est ça c'est hier
aujourd'hui et puis demain
ou pas la mort voilà avec avec une
histoire aussi sentimentale qui est en
train de se créer entre deux jeunes
voilà ça donne envie oui oui
on en reparlera
Sandrine
je sais pas si elle est encore connectée
avec nous merci infiniment le festival
c'est tous les ans le festival
ent voyager sur plusieurs villes et près
de faire New York ou Washington et une
ville au Canada comme ça devrait être un
joli parcours parce que Didier comme les
autres auteurs m'ont dit c'est trop
court une journée il faut qu'on reste
plus longtemps ensemble il faut qu'on
fasse mieux connaissance donc voilà le
programme va être plus long oui vous
savez que maintenant quand on prend
l'avion il faut
[Rires]
optimiser
merci infiniment Sandrine merez et bravo
bravo pour tout ce que vous faites pour
la pour la France pour la culture
française aux États-Unis et Didier
Kimmel merci et bravo et voilà donc les
roses bleues c'est toujours voilà
le livre et puis je ne serai jamais loin
de toi c'est dans quelque chose on en
reparlera oui tout à fait merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
[Musique]